GOPI KALLAYIL: Good afternoon.
We live in an astonishingly
interesting time in that of
the 7 billion people on the
planet, 2 billion are on the
internet and 6 billion
have cellphones.
So this has become the
most pervasive
technology in human history.
More people carry one of these
devices than have access to
clean drinking water
or electricity.
And arguably, all of this
technology in humanity has
increased the productivity,
but it also means we are
drowning in the information that
comes towards us through
these technologies.
The amount of email that keeps
flooding towards us and the
extent to which our lives are
now accessed by other people
sending us information through
all of these media, whether
it's text, or email,
or other means.
So on the one hand, it does
increase productivity, on the
other hand, we also
feel overwhelmed.
Into this field has stepped in
Jared Goralnick, one of the
foremost experts on how do we
live a more productive, sane,
and happier life while still
using all of these
technologies.
In fact, Jared was so convinced
about this topic
that he has become part of the
leadership team at the
Information Overload
Research Group.
He founded two companies.
First, a consulting company
to help people deal with
productivity issues.
And currently, he is the
founder/CEO of a company
called AwayFind that builds
software to help us deal with
information overload and
increase our productivity.
With that, let me turn it over
to our speaker, Jared
Goralnick, to help us improve
our productivity across all
forms of our life.
Jared?
JARED GORALNICK: That's
quite the intro.
Thank you so much, Gopi.
And thank you all so much
for coming out.
It's quite a privilege
to be here.
So that's a lot about me.
I'd love to start by
just learning a
little bit about you.
I'll have some general
questions
and then some specifics.
But first off, just out of
curiosity, which teams are
folks coming from?
How many are coming
from Search?
Some people here.
OK, Search.
Ad side of that?
OK.
Gmail?
I know there's some
Gmail folks.
Yay, I hope to make an impact
there some day.
There will be a little bit of
email in this presentation.
+?
We've got some + folks.
Great.
Maps?
I was hoping.
I guess they're busy today.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
JARED GORALNICK: Any
other teams?
What other folks are here?
Anybody shout out, feel free.
AUDIENCE: Android.
JARED GORALNICK: Android.
Ah, of course, yes.
AUDIENCE: YouTube.
JARED GORALNICK:
YouTube, great.
And also, this is up on
YouTube right now.
Any other teams?
AUDIENCE: Platforms.
JARED GORALNICK: Platforms,
great.
Awesome.
And then how many of you
folks are engineers?
How many of you are marketing?
OK.
Product management?
HR?
Awesome.
Folks helping with video?
OK, great.
So we have a bit of a
distribution in here.
Just in terms of my background,
I sort of still am
an engineer.
I do more product now.
But I was coding at
seven and whatnot.
And then I went on and got a
software engineering degree.
But then I got a philosophy
degree.
And I mention that because a lot
of this is not about these
little tools, it's about the why
we're doing all of this.
Like my first company
was called
Software Efficiency Training.
That's kind of the wrong word
because "efficiency" is sort
of assembly line stuff.
It's how do you produce
more widgets?
The word "productivity" is a
little bit better, it sort of
seems to imply if we're more
productive, we get a little
bit more choice about what we
do that theoretically makes
more impact or maybe
we can spend more
time with our family.
That's the hope of all this.
And to illustrate that, maybe
I can start with an analogy.
How many of you speak
a second language?
A third language?
Fourth?
Fifth?
OK, so you, sir, in the back,
in the green shirt, four
languages, what's one of the
languages you speak?
AUDIENCE: Well, of course,
English, Hindi, Marathi, and a
bit of French.
JARED GORALNICK: And a
bit of French, OK.
So Marathi, where do you
speak that, in India?
AUDIENCE: Mostly India.
JARED GORALNICK: OK, so anybody
here been to India
that does not speak a
local dialect there?
OK, great.
And what's your name
in the green?
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Deborah.
JARED GORALNICK: Deborah.
And did you have a good time
when you were in India?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JARED GORALNICK: It was
an experience, yeah?
And other folks that went to
India, you probably got a lot
of that experience, but you had
a different experience.
And I'm sorry, what is
your name again?
You in the back, I'm sorry.
I didn't ask you for
your name before.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Mans.
JARED GORALNICK: Mans.
OK, so Mans speaks several
local dialects
and other folks don't.
And they both went to
India and they both
were able to get by.
And productivity is actually
kind of like language in that
way, in that if you have
fluency, there is a lot more
depth that is possible
in your experiences.
And without that, you all still
can get a lot done, but
what happens is there's certain
things you just can't
choose to do.
And I personally believe that
Google does not pay you to be
productive.
That's not their goal.
Their goal is for you
to do something that
achieves real scale.
They want you to do something
that's going to make one
engineer not worth the $1
million and a half that
they're supposedly worth if you
divide the numbers based
on employees, but more that
they're worth $1 billion
because they build the next
AdWords, or the next Gmail, or
the next Android platform.
So what I'm going to talk about
today is really a series
of sort of tools like a language
where I hope you will
all sort of embrace them because
they're an opportunity
to then have more freedom
and choice in how
you spend your time.
And I'm going to start off with
email and with several
little tweaks.
These are kind of like the
vocabulary of a language.
They are little things that you
can change and that you
can do right away that can
make what I hope to be a
dramatic impact.
The second part of my
presentation will be about
some of the techniques and
sort of the concepts, or
almost like the grammar in a
language and how this applies.
And the reason why I'm going
back to language is because,
again, how many people are
familiar with like "Getting
Things Done?" OK.
How many are productivity
adherents to some kind of
system or another?
Right?
OK, cool.
So it's good that you're not all
that way because I think
these systems, it's sort of like
being like, oh, I'm an
Agile guy, or oh, I'm a Python
guy, or like all
these little labels.
That's not what I want
this to be about.
I want this to be about
something where we recognize
that these are tools that are
necessary if we want to avoid
that sudden death that I
mentioned in here, if we want
to be able to get off that
hamster wheel and
do something important.
So starting with a pretty simple
thing, if you're on
Google+, and you're on Facebook,
and you're on
Twitter, and even Amazon, all
these sites, they send you a
lot of emails, right?
But most of those emails are
things that we never need to
let into our life.
So it's very easy to change
the inputs in our life.
And one of the easiest ways to
do that is just simply to
unsubscribe from the messages
we don't need.
We as product folks know that
all these messages are how we
build engagement, all these
emails we send to folks.
And of course, Google+ does
that when I get a new
connection and so forth.
But I would encourage you to
just spend five minutes
sometime later today, all of
these slides are up, the link
is at the end of this.
But I would encourage you
to spend five minutes.
You can go to notifymenot.com.
That's a site that I created
that walks through all the
sites, or many of the major
sites, and tells you how to
turn off some of the
notifications.
But instead, if you just get
the personal messages that
come from +, or from Facebook,
or from Flickr, or from
Amazon, or whatever
it happens to be.
On Amazon the example would be
like the shipment changed its
arrival date.
You don't need to know that
the shipment was made, it
always is made.
It's only if there's an alert
that actually demands your
attention that it should ever
show up in your inbox.
So if you change these inputs,
you'll have less stuff sort of
weighing you down.
And then similarly, Gopi, you
talked about 6 billion phones
or something.
It's amazing.
We carry these things in our
pockets that have this amazing
ability to connect us, but also
to pull us away from what
we're doing right now.
Nobody wakes up in the morning
and says they want to check
their email all day and
that's where they want
to spend their time.
But similarly, nobody walks
into a meeting and says, I
can't wait to find out about
the stuff that's happening
outside of here.
Or maybe if it's a certain kind
of meeting, you might
feel that way.
But we, in just about one or two
minutes, can turn off all
of those notifications.
Because probably 1 in every 100
of those messages really
demands our time right now.
And there's a URL there again
for how to turn those off on
Android and other devices.
How many of you have more
than 100 messages in
your inbox right now?
Great that a lot of
the Gmail people
didn't raise their hand.
More than 1,000?
More than 15,000?
OK, good.
So 10,000, that's a
lot of messages.
It's interesting.
What I like to think of the
inbox as, it's the place where
other people set your agenda.
So compare it to a task list.
A task list has two things.
There's only two things
that are important
about a task list.
One is that you can change
the order around.
And two is that you can give
it a title that you
understand, that you
can work with.
Whereas email, you could be
doing Re: hey, and it could
have some important assignment
in there.
Or it could relate to something
a bunch of steps
down after the conversation
changed topics three times.
And then, of course, it's just
chronological based on when
somebody sent it to you.
It's a really awful place to
spend a lot of your day.
So anything you can do to get
things out of your inbox is a
very positive thing.
It's the place where
you don't want your
attention to be sapped.
And you definitely don't want to
be seeing the same message
over and over.
So I think there's this
technology that you guys have
in Gmail that allows you
to find messages
that have been archived.
I won't name it, there's
some people who work
on that team here.
But you can use that to
find those messages.
And I encourage you to
press Archive All.
And then it gives you another
option that lets you literally
archive everything in your
entire inbox, not just those
20 or 50 messages
on that screen.
And Gopi, you went
through that.
How was that experience?
GOPI KALLAYIL: Scary.
Jumping off a cliff.
JARED GORALNICK: Scary?
And what happened?
Did you land after you
got off the cliff?
GOPI KALLAYIL: I survived.
JARED GORALNICK: For a little
while, it feels quite amazing.
And if you can maintain, it's
not that you need inbox zero,
it's that you just don't want
to constantly be revisiting
things and having that feeling
of not knowing what's next.
And here's a picture up here.
This is Suzanne here.
This picture was
taken in 1985.
She's pretty cute.
I was all right back then when
I was four years old.
But I have a feeling that
she has moved on.
I know I have to sort of give
up on this opportunity here.
And this message has been
uploaded all over
the place by now.
I think I can delete
it from my inbox.
I think a lot of the reason why
we have so many messages
is because we think there's
something we need to find.
But we have tools to find it.
So whether you're archiving or
you're deleting, you've got to
move on from those messages.
And I think you'll find yourself
so much more sane and
so much more able to do things
that are remarkable.
And I've already talked about
what enters into your inbox
and what grabs your attention
from your mobile device or
maybe some of you even
have pop-ups.
Not in Outlook, but you might
have one of those Chrome
extensions that shows you
when you get new mail.
Turn those off and don't
continue to check email.
I have spent much of my career
focused on this concept of
interruptions.
And that's what my product
does, AwayFind.
I don't know if you're aware,
but we lose about four minutes
to every interruption and the
rabbit hole it sends us down.
Studies show that if you're
getting over 100 messages a
day, that will turn into about
a quarter of your day is lost
in interruptions and the time it
takes to get back on track.
And the main step to fixing that
is closing your inbox,
closing your Gmail
more of the day.
You will never forget to check
it, I promise you.
So close it, not just
during the holidays.
And if you'd like to learn more
about that, you can go to
awayfind.com.
I don't know if you're allowed
to use my product at Google,
but there is a guide to not
checking email that's been
downloaded over 100,000 times.
And that's just free as
part of our setup.
And I hope it helps.
It gives some more tactical
steps for this material.
So that's it for email.
Any quick questions about email
stuff before I jump on?
We'll have a chance at the end
if you guys want to hear all
my opinions about things
that could happen in
change in that world.
Second section here is
about productivity.
And first off, those of you
that raised your hand with
"Getting Things Done," you're
familiar with the mind like
water metaphor?
Anybody remember that,
mind like water?
Great, is it something that's
been helpful to you?
Have you ever applied that?
AUDIENCE: I did.
I sat still and made
a crazy long list.
And I achieved mind like
water, and then I had
a crazy long list.
I didn't know what to do next.
I'm hoping you can tell
me right now.
JARED GORALNICK: I will
tell you right now.
AUDIENCE: Right now.
JARED GORALNICK: OK.
So mind like water, it's the
concept that if you picture a
little pond, and you picture a
rock falling into that pond,
how does the pond respond?
Exactly appropriately, it makes
little ripples at the
angle, and weight, and momentum,
et cetera, based on
how you dropped that
rock in there.
Now picture yourself having
a harried day.
Maybe this afternoon is going
to be particularly busy for
you and you just crammed
this session in.
And somebody comes to you
and says, you know what?
There's this bug, and it's
actually live, and it's a
really big issue.
Now, how do you respond?
Do you respond appropriately
by walking over to your
terminal, looking at what's
going on, seeing how many
people are doing it?
Or do you flip out and scream
because you're thinking about
the people you have to pick up
later today, you're thinking
about the other tasks you have
to do, you're thinking about
all this stuff going on?
You are not like that rock
falling into the pond if you
have all kinds of things
on your mind.
So the goal of any productivity
system, anything,
it doesn't matter, is to get
things out of your head and
into a place that you can trust
so that when new things
come at you, or when you get to
an item on your task list,
you can actually focus on that
and not be overwhelmed by all
that other stuff.
Now, the first step to getting
things out of your head is
putting it somewhere else.
Now, you could put it
into Google Tasks.
You could put it into some other
project management tool.
But the main thing is just
getting it out of your head
because the reality is you're
probably not going to get
through all those things.
But the first thing, the first
step, is to literally just
write it all down.
It's cathartic, it's liberating,
it's amazing, just
getting it out of your head.
Now, you're right, you're
going to end up with
this big task list.
And that might seem
overwhelming.
But first off, you can at
least reorganize that as
opposed to like your
inbox and whatnot.
But second of all, you're going
to probably find that
you'll never get to half
of your tasks.
I mean, there are things
you have to do.
There's a deadline, you
need to show up
somewhere, or whatever.
But there's a lot of tasks
you will never get to.
And we have to accept that.
We all in this room have to
accept that there is more in
life that we want to
do than we will be
able to actually do.
But at least get it out of your
head and have it there in
a bucket list, so maybe even
five years from now you will
get back to it.
Just get it out of your head,
and that's the first step.
Knowing that is there
is totally fine.
I recognize that I have a to-do
list for today that I
actually care about and that I
have a giant list that's out
of sight, out of mind, and maybe
that doesn't sound so
good, but it feels a heck
of a lot better.
So get yourself that
mind like water.
And then, you guys are a company
that focuses on data.
You have lots of things
you can measure.
And now quantified self, we
have like seven different
devices we can carry around
on ourselves to measure
everything we do.
I got into social media
a long time ago.
I mean, now I'm not.
We don't even say we're into
social media, that's not cool.
But back in like 2006 and 2007,
when things were really
starting to heat up again with
blogs, and Twitter was coming
on to the fore, and we were
all watching our follower
count, and our friend number,
and all that stuff.
And there's all these numbers
that are around us.
And if you find that you're
checking statistics all the
time, regardless of what
statistics they are, think
about whether it's something
that is a key performance
indicator for the value of your
work or something you're
trying to change in your life.
Because if it's not, there's a
good chance it's more just
weighing you down.
And maybe it makes you feel good
when you get that extra
number or maybe it makes you
feel awful, but if it doesn't
really change something in your
life or in your work,
maybe you should just
stop checking it.
There's probably a lot
of numbers around.
You think about which ones
you can let go of.
Maybe do it once a week or
maybe set a Cron job that
sends it to you once a week so
you don't have to check it
every three hours if
there's been new
sign ups on your product.
Another thing, it's called
the Pomodoro
Technique or Pomodoro Method.
I see a lot of folks here
are familiar with that.
It's the idea of getting
yourself into something for 50
minutes and focusing on it and
then moving on for about 10
minutes and maybe going to one
of your mini cafes, or talking
to someone, or having some
other kind of challenge.
You can google Pomodoro, like
the type of tomato.
And this is just one
of the techniques.
I'm going to go into flow
a little bit more.
But this is just one of the many
concepts I think that's
worth researching if
you're getting into
this type of material.
We've got folks here from the +
team, and I love your little
notification that pops
up all the time.
But we as people who are
knowledge workers, we do have
other responsibilities besides
the main task at hand.
And in that 10 minutes or in
that time that you dedicate to
doing social media or keeping
up with other things, I'd
recommend going 100%
into those things.
Jump into that stream of social
media, or of analytics,
or whatever it happens to be,
and then get out of it.
As opposed to having the little
alerts that pop up at
different times.
This is just like with email,
but with other things.
It's OK to have distractions,
but I recommend batching them,
putting them in one
little place.
Jump into that stream, and
then jump out of it.
And also unplug.
I mentioned making
a giant list.
I mentioned pressing Archive
All to get a
little bit more clarity.
But it's amazing, I bought
the most expensive
paper I could buy.
I think it was $15 for 108
brightness and 32 pound paper,
whatever it happens to be.
But it is liberating to just
have that sheet of paper and
get those ideas out.
It's true, there's going to be
periods where you have to
spend 6, or 20, or 50 hours over
a certain period of time
writing an article or coding a
particular module, whatever it
happens to be.
But there are times where you
really just need clarity and
there's just something to be
said for paper or turning off
the internet.
So try to add that into
your routine.
Anybody ever been productive on
a train or a plane before?
Why not recreate that one
hour of every day, that
opportunity?
In my mornings, I try to have
a bit of time every day
without internet activity.
And it's amazing what you can
get done in that period.
Even if you have a few sites you
need for that work, just
bring them up and in a tab in
Chrome, and then do the other
stuff, and you have
them there.
And even make a list for the
things you're going to have to
do when you're back online.
But it's amazing what you'll
get done a little bit when
you're offline.
Plus, you have your phones
and a million
other ways to connect.
I even like taking this further
and creating what I
like to call a "cone of
silence." This idea that you
literally just have one thing
you're super focused on.
And I know I keep drilling
into this point.
But it's interesting
with email.
Most of us consume it at various
points in our day and
probably various points
in an hour.
I think studies range between
18 to 36 times per hour.
You guys have much better
data on that, I'm sure.
But that was in the most recent
Gloria Mark study.
They referenced that.
That's a lot of time to
constantly check your email.
That means that any given one
task you're doing, you're
spending less than four
minutes on it.
The truth is, though, if you
make email your job, if you
literally say, for the next 45
minutes I'm going to do email,
you will get through what you
need to get through in there.
You'll be able to process it,
create tasks from it.
You can all watch the
Inbox Zero talk
that was Merlin Mann.
You probably have all seen
it, that he did here.
It's a great way to learn
all the processing
techniques for email.
But if you give yourself 40
minutes to really get into
that inbox, or really get into
that article, or that UX
workflow, or whatever it happens
to be, it's insane
what you can get out of it.
And I know, again, I'm stressing
the same point, but
give yourself that cone of
silence and you will do
something amazing with
that period of time.
Also, think about the essential
and the incidental.
There's a URL here,
bit.ly/thecriticalpath.
And I have a whole article that
I talk about how to write
out a sheet of paper and
figure out what your
critical path is.
But the concept of critical path
refers to at the end of
this year, at the end of this
quarter, or just in my life,
here's something that really,
really needs to happen.
Maybe it's that we get a million
users, maybe it's that
we increase adoption by this
percent, maybe it's that we
bring on this many brands to
our product, whatever it
happens to be.
But if you look at your task
list, that giant list you have
of 100 plus items, I will bet
you that most of those things,
probably more than half of them,
won't actually relate to
that specific goal.
And that's what's fascinating is
we have this critical path
and most things aren't on it.
And then all of a sudden it gets
really easy if you say to
yourself, in the mornings, I'm
never going to do something
that's not on my
critical path.
I know I have to respond to
emails, I know there's this
birthday thing coming up, I
know there's these talks I
want to see.
But in my mornings, I'm only
going to do things on my
critical path.
And amazingly, you will
get forward with it.
It's just like the whole if you
spend 30 minutes a day on
something forever, you're going
to be the world's expert
in that thing or one of.
So consider what is incidental
and what is
essential, what is critical.
And try to fill your
day as much as
possible with those things.
It's a really great heuristic
for limiting tasks.
And then circadian rhythms.
This is one of these concepts
that sounds kind of
loosey-goosey, I don't know.
Like I have different
flow states at
different times of day.
But the reality is, if you
think about it, you have
different energy levels at
different times of the day.
And if you have the ability to
manipulate your schedule a
little bit, you can structure
it so that you do the right
work for that energy level.
So for me, what does
that mean?
It means that I don't do
meetings before lunch.
Why is that?
It's because I have energy and
I have focus at that time,
before lunch that is.
I do my most creative
work before lunch.
And that's amazing for me.
Now when I'm sitting down in
a meeting, particularly if
there's a cup of coffee or
something, I mean I am going
to have no trouble.
If I'm sitting with Gopi at 3:00
in the afternoon, he has
my attention, I'm never
going to mess that up.
But if I'm sitting with an
article to write or a spec to
draw out, I'm going to find
everything else to do, and I'm
going to be completely all over
the place because I don't
have the same attention
in the afternoons.
So think about how your day
works and your energy levels,
and see if there's a way you
can adapt your day a
little bit to it.
And along the same line, just
walking down the cafeteria
here I see lots of people eating
food that who knows if
it's the best thing for them
to be eating right now in
terms of giving themself
energy for
the rest of the day.
But think about how the
food you consume
relates to your energy.
For me, for example, I do all
protein in the morning and
just about all protein
in the afternoon.
Or rather, I don't
touch carbs.
It's not that I do
all protein.
And by cutting carbs out
of my morning and my
afternoon, it's amazing.
When I used to eat cereal or
bagels in morning, which I
loved, I would be tired
or at like 10:30 or
11:00 I'd be hungry.
And I'm not saying that's the
solution for you, but it's
amazing how we really are slaves
to our bodies and we
can really schedule our days and
consider our intakes based
on these kinds of things.
And this is actually
my last slide here.
It's coming near the
end of the year.
And it's one of those times
where we start looking back
and thinking about the things
we've accomplished.
And I've been doing a
bit of that lately.
Maybe this won't come as a
surprise, but I've realized
the things that have made the
biggest impact on my company
and upon myself, there's
two things about them.
One is that those things were
never assigned to me.
Nobody told me to do that.
My investors, my board,
my team, friends
didn't suggest it.
I'm sure you've probably seen
that users of your products
rarely suggest the things that
are the best features because
they're not in it
the same way.
Maybe they are, but generally
speaking, they're thinking one
step out and you're thinking
four steps out.
And for me, I found that, again,
those things weren't
assigned to me.
And similarly, they were
the things where I had
to put in 100 hours.
Even though I probably could
have done that same thing in
10 hours and it would've
been OK.
So there's a lot of things in
your job that you do that you
do good enough, you maybe even
do it really well because
you're just a smart person.
Everybody in this room, I'm
sure, is incredibly
intelligent.
And then there's other things,
though, that you probably know
you could either do it better
or, even more, it's the area
where you are just
like the best.
There's something where you're
in the 99 point something
percentile.
And when you do those things,
you've probably found that you
can get amazing results
with that.
So when I write like my guide to
not checking email, it was
just something that nobody
told me to do.
And it got amazing, amazing
attention from it.
There's certain things that
I've done in my life, like
when I wrote the guide to
Outlook versus Gmail, that,
back in the day, got hundreds of
thousands of views and made
it to the front page of Digg.
And it was this giant article
that was a big risk for me,
but I put everything into it.
And every time I've put
everything into something,
I've got insane results back.
So when you think about your
to-do lists, think about
what's not on your to-do
list and think about
what you're best at.
And maybe you can do something
that's remarkable as opposed
to something that's
just productive.
Hopefully with fluency in these
tools, you can free up a
little bit of time
in your days.
Maybe you have that 20% time,
maybe it feels like you have
the 20% percent time
but don't.
But if you can have that time to
do something that is going
to scale, I think you'll
be amazed with what
comes out of it.
So you can get in touch
with me by Google.
No, you don't have to do
that, I'm just kidding.
Here's my information.
I'd love to keep in touch with
all of you, but now I have
time for questions.
Actually, well, I'll bring up
my calendar for one sec just
to show kind of a
quick tip here.
So here's yesterday
on my calendar.
And I think you're bringing that
up because we had talked
about this stuff last
time we had met.
Has anybody ever been
to an appointment?
What's your name, sir,
in the blue?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Frank.
JARED GORALNICK: Frank.
Have you ever scheduled an
appointment that says meeting
with Frank?
Has somebody ever sent you
that calendar invite?
How useful is that to you?
We all do that.
Well, actually, I don't do that
anymore, it's terrible.
I laugh at people when
they do that.
Every single time I create an
appointment, I put what kind
of appointment it is, coffee,
Skype, lunch, colon.
And then I put my name first
and then I put their name.
And they love that and it looks
great in their calendar.
They know what's going on.
It indicates whether you need
to be somewhere else or
whether you don't need to be,
whether you need video or not.
But the main thing is never
ever create a meeting.
I would never email Trevor and
say meeting with Trevor
because he has to then look into
the attendee list to find
out who I am.
And I had a meeting with
somebody the other day where
they did that and their Gmail
address was instructively.
I didn't even know
who they were.
So that is my calendar tip.
Always indicate what type of
meeting it is, put your name,
if you need to, parentheses
Google, dash their name, if
you need to, parentheses
their company.
Good question.
Frank?
AUDIENCE: Like the gentleman
behind me, once you create
that giant list, the anxiety of
that list, like every time
I've done the full on GTD sort
of thing collecting that list,
there's enough anxiety to it
that, one, is just going
through it takes a lot of time
and taking out value from it.
And then you start creating
these hack lists where this is
the real list of the things I
want to get done and you start
ignoring that thing
almost entirely.
And so after a couple weeks,
that list is deprecated, it's
no longer of value, and
so you've captured it.
How have you dealt with that?
Because that giant list,
especially at Google, that
list can be pretty sizable.
JARED GORALNICK:
It makes sense.
So I know in GTD they
talk about context.
They say you should have your
list for when you're in your
car, or your home, or
different things.
I don't do all of that.
I just have a list of things
that I'm actually really going
to do, or that I actually
have to do today.
And then I have a list of things
that I need to do that
I really do need to do.
And then I just have this giant
list that someday maybe.
And the soon list, I
look at every week.
It's probably like
45, 50 items.
The today list, I take
some things from it.
And it doesn't mean that I
always get them done today.
But it never gets to more
than like 10 items.
I try to keep it more like
three or four items.
So I have my things that
I really have to do.
I have the things that I hope
to really do today.
And then I have this giant
list that I might look at
every month or so.
And when I'm going through soon,
sometimes I move it to
the forever, who knows,
whatever list,
and sometimes I don't.
I do have other lists, but
they're more lists of
restaurants, or movies, or
people's names I don't want to
forget, things like that.
I try to keep those off of the
things that are actionable and
that I have to really
pay attention to.
Because those I actually will
go back to look at.
You know, I walk into the coffee
house, I'm like, I know
I know that person, I'm
going to look that up.
Like that's me accessing
it that way.
But I really try to keep the
actionable, necessary stuff.
Those are the only things I
look at on a weekly basis.
AUDIENCE: So what are your tips
for when you work with
systems like GTD and
to-do lists?
How do you not let it focus you
on the small tasks and do
something bigger?
JARED GORALNICK: Well, it
helps to know what your
critical path is.
What is one of the
most important
things for your work?
AUDIENCE: What I noticed, when
I really try and get into
these productivity systems, they
take your attention away
from the big picture and
onto these little
chunks, little tasks.
These little tasks are very
optimized to do efficiently
and be productive
on that level.
But at the end of the day, all
you have is a list of these
small little tasks that you've
done and not your
big project, maybe.
So I wonder what your
suggestions are.
How do you keep the focus on
the big picture while using
those systems?
JARED GORALNICK: So I
think there's two
components to that.
One component of it is the
fact that you have
some sort of review.
Like the evening before you
spend like literally two
minutes and you're
like, what do I
want to get done tomorrow?
So you have some idea about what
is on the big project you
want to do.
And the second part of it is,
and this is where some people,
I think, make the mistake of
when to use a calendar versus
when to use a task.
You shouldn't put all your
tasks in your calendar.
You all know probably the basic
why you don't but your
tasks in your calendar.
It's because the next day, if
you didn't do it, it's now
disappeared.
But the task didn't disappear.
So that's why you don't
just use your calendar
for your task list.
However, that's why I
was suggesting how I
structure my day.
So the thing that you really
need to do that's on your big
list, you can use your
calendar for that.
You can say, two hours.
Or you can say like what I do,
I just know that it's my
mornings is going
to be my really,
really important stuff.
So recognizing that when I look
for what I'm going to do
tomorrow, something
really important
has to happen tomorrow.
And then, if necessary,
block that time out.
Or if you just generally
understand how your schedule
works, then don't.
And then spend your time on
little to-do list stuff.
The five minute things I like
to block all at once.
You know, a bunch of phone
calls, and silly phone calls
too, not even really important
work meeting phone calls.
I try to batch those.
I had a postcard the other
day I picked up.
I should have brought it and put
it on this presentation.
Something like, I can't do any
big things because I'm always
spending time on the
little things.
So you need to block out
those big things.
You don't have to necessarily
put it in your calendar, but
really just make sure that you
know every day when you're
going to being do that.
Because if you don't do that,
you're never going to feel
like you accomplished
anything.
And people say to do it
first thing in the
morning if you can.
I like doing that, some
people don't.
But if you do the major, major
important stuff first thing,
what's great about it is then
all the stuff that piled up
from your inbox and the other
tasks you have to do, you can
deal with them the rest of the
day, but at least you got
something really major
done that morning.
AUDIENCE: So what I've noticed
about new organizational
systems, new management systems,
is that it's not so
much the things that you already
know to do, it's the
things that you don't know
that you have to do, the
sudden interruption, the sudden
high priority thing
that you did not accommodate
or plan for.
Like you get sick or something
major happens and it blows
apart your priorities.
And therefore, once that
disruption happens, you can't
recover back, so you sort
of just go on the
way you used to.
How do you handle that?
JARED GORALNICK: Well, that's
the beauty of having a
shorter task list.
And what I mean by that is
like if you have that now
list, then today when you get
sick or somebody comes in with
a real emergency, yeah,
your day is screwed.
Like I can't fix the problem
where you have seven hours
worth of stuff to
do in four hours
today, it can't be fixed.
But if that next day, before
you start your day or
whatever, you are going
to recalibrate and
say, you know what?
I'm just not going to be
able to do that thing.
I'm even going to tell him
that I can't finish
that thing on time.
If you give yourself that
opportunity every day to set
what your task list is for the
next day, then when you would
get one of these catastrophic
things, you are able to just
manipulate what you're doing
the next day as opposed to
just having this list of 100
things and now you just never
get to look at the other 99
because you just have one
that's at the top.
Now, this may sound like I'm
just saying I'm skirting
around the problem.
But I really think most of this
stuff is psychological.
And what I mean by that is like
when crises happen, we
always get through it.
It's up to us, though, of
whether during that crisis we
want to also feel overwhelmed
by every single time we look
at the place, whether it be our
inbox or our task list,
that sort of dictates how we
should be spending our time.
If every time we look at that
we're also overwhelmed.
So if you can respect yourself
enough to say that if I make
it out of sight, out of mind,
I'm going to live with that,
then you'll make some hard
decisions and move some things
off your today list into
the soon list.
And just accept that certain
things won't get done.
But it's better to tell yourself
I'm not going to do
this then to try to just pretend
that adding a bunch of
crazy stuff into your list is
somehow going to happen.
Because all you can do
with that is time.
You have to say no
to some things.
But I think the best way to say
no to that is every day to
have a little bit of a conscious
decision about what
you want to accomplish
that day or the next.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
regarding how to make this
to-do list itself.
So right now, my to-do lists are
kind of scattered over a
few things, like I have a few
labels on the emails like to
do or something.
And I have like a bug list,
which me and my peers and my
manager keep filling, and
that's my to-do list.
And then I have like a to-do
list, like a special list
which I make.
So my question is, how do you
make this to-do list?
Because if I start making one
giant to-do list, basically
I'll be scraping the emails
again and again to put into
this list, whereas it's easier
to just keep the labels.
Same with bugs.
Like if I want to keep just one
list, I'll have to keep
scraping the bugs and then
like note down the minute
details of that in
my to-do list.
So I'm kind of recreating
some of the bug, which
is easier to do.
But at the same time, I do get
distracted with the emails
that pop up.
So my question is, how do you
deal with making this to-do
list itself efficiently
without having to
redo a lot of work?
JARED GORALNICK: Sure.
So everybody here probably
knows you have the Add To
Tasks List menu option, and you
also have the shortcut for
it, to take an email and
turn it into a task.
So that's what I do as just
a starting point.
And just about every project
management tool will notify
you via email.
So for me, I'm not wasting
that many steps to turn
something from an email or
something from some other
project management tool
into now a task.
But that being said, you have
to ask yourself, are you
comfortable with having multiple
things to check?
So for me, for example, I know
I'm going to check my calendar
a bunch of times a day.
I know I'm going to look
at my today list a
bunch of times today.
And I'm probably going to
look at my soon list at
least once every day.
Beyond that, I mean I know
I'm going to check
my Facebook or something.
But beyond that, it's hard for
me to trust myself that I'm
going to go to those
other places.
If you can get yourself to do
that, then by all means have
multiple lists.
If you can't, then you do have
to put it in one place.
But that's a learning thing.
Can you get yourself to have
four, or five, or six?
And you might be.
I mean, there's lots of people
that everything comes from
their ticketing tracking
system.
And they spend so much time
there that they don't need it
to be in their box too.
Like on my team, most of my team
does use the ticketing
tracking system as their
dominant place.
Me personally, I'm doing
less of that.
So I rely more on my
primary task list.
AUDIENCE: So do you scrape the
emails to create the task as
they come or do you dedicate
a certain time for it?
Like would you say, OK, in the
mornings I won't check, but in
the afternoon I'll dedicate
like 45 minutes to create
tasks out of them
or something?
JARED GORALNICK: So creating
tasks, it's not as hard an
effort as it sounds in the sense
that I'm literally task
and archive.
That's it.
And then I give it a different
title if I need to.
That's when you say
"creating t--"
Now, of course, how I process
my email, I try not to do it
in the morning.
And then usually, before lunch,
around 11:30 or so,
I'll spend some time on my task
list, or rather on my
inbox processing.
Some things I immediately reply
to, some things I put on
the task list, other things
I just archive
or delete, et cetera.
Straight out of your inbox zero
technique, if you will.
But what's important, though,
is I'm just saying that that
transition from email
notification into task is a
very quick effort.
We're talking a couple
seconds.
AUDIENCE: It's still
distracting though.
JARED GORALNICK: Well, but
here's the thing, though, once
it's in the task list, I feel
like I have control over it.
The thing with the email
is you don't have any
control over it.
You can't rename it, you
can't reorder it.
So once it's in my task list,
it might start staring me
down, but at least I can move
it, at least I can rename it,
at least I can prioritize it in
some way, in some way that
I have control over.
And really, I think all
of productivity, in a
collaborative environment, all
of it is, how can I be
responsive without constantly
being reactive?
So getting back to people in
three hours, that's fine,
that's responsive.
Getting back to people in five
minutes, that's unsustainable.
That's creating an expectation
that they're more
important than you.
Our product helps with making
sure that people you do need
to get back to right
away, you can.
But generally speaking, most
things don't demand your time
right right now.
So anything you can do to set
that expectation I think is a
good thing.
And I think moving it to your
task list is a much better
place than leaving
it in your inbox.
AUDIENCE: Pretty awesome.
I just stumbled by, and thanks
for coming to us to speak.
This is a point, you're almost
talking about how you manage
the big projects versus like
the day-to-day tasks.
I believe there's some function
in between which
daily translates the big
projects and the concrete
steps and turns them into
your daily tasks.
Like what's the right system or
I guess what have you found
that really works for you?
Because personally, I understand
the email and
translating it to like daily
tasks, but it's that project
part that's even harder.
JARED GORALNICK: I mean this is
where there's two different
approaches.
There's David Allen would say
put the absolute next step on
your task list, this way
there's no barrier.
So for example, if you have to
call somebody, and it's just
call Steve.
Well, now you have to look up
Steve's number, and you have
to look up whatever the ticket
number it relates to is, and
all this other stuff.
And then you're not going
to do it, right?
So there is something to be said
for making sure that if
you put it in your task list it
relates to a big project,
get it there so there's
no barriers for you
starting with it, right?
If it's something that you need
to spend an hour on as
opposed to something really
discrete, really specific,
that's where, again, the
calendar can come in and help
a little bit.
Or if you trust yourself enough,
in other words, like
to the extent that you have
something bigger to
accomplish, describe
it that way for
yourself in the task list.
If you need to check in a
particular fix and that's
going to take 45 minutes, just
put that in your task list.
If you really need to block out
the time, then put it in
your calendar.
Unfortunately, all I can do
is help people to remove
barriers, which means gathering
all the information
you possibly can, so that when
you see it in your task list
you don't just go
away from it.
And I definitely don't want you
to have to create like 600
tasks that you're always going
to do them in a row.
In other words, if two things
have to happen in a row, and
always have to happen in a row,
you shouldn't make them
two tasks, per se, unless you're
just saving yourself
time by doing it that way.
But the real thing is just
figuring out for yourself what
removes barriers and what
provides clarity for you.
Again, all this stuff, getting
off the hamster wheel, is so
that you have enough time to
have clarity, whether it be in
reprioritizing or deciding
what's going to make the most
impact for you.
AUDIENCE: As you're going
specifically from email to a
task list, if you're getting
emails which are long, and
complex, and four paragraphs,
and have links off to other
things, and it's not entirely
clear what the point is, as
you're going from the email to
the task list, do you take the
time to read the email, think
about what the tasks are, and
then put those on
the task list?
Or do you kind of have something
where it's like
you're dumping like deal with
this email on the task list?
Does that make sense?
JARED GORALNICK: In a perfect
world, I'll take out the bits
that are actionable.
In reality, sometimes I'm just
trying to get this stuff off
of my plate.
So it really depends on how
much time you have.
If you can break it into
discrete things, it's better.
What's great, though, is that
you preserve the URL.
I want the Tasks team here to
fix the ability to move tasks
on a mobile device between task
lists without losing the
URL linking to emails.
Right now it breaks if
you move from one
task list to another.
It breaks the URL if you do it
on a mobile device or anything
with the API.
I would love that fix
to be in place.
But again, as long as you have
the URL, that at least is your
get out of jail free card.
You just want to know enough
in the email that you don't
have to deal with
this right now.
And as long as you've eliminated
that, it's OK to
process it later.
AUDIENCE: Actually, a lot of us
spend quite a bit of time
in meetings as well.
And I'm wondering if you have
any general thoughts on how to
make meetings most efficient
as well.
JARED GORALNICK: There's
a lot to that.
It's like everything in life,
the more you prepare, the
better it is when you show up.
And a lot of people use meetings
to just like be a
handholding to start
accomplishing things when the
reality is you should be going
there to report or discuss the
things that really do
need deliberation.
I guess one tip I'll just
throw out is just when
brainstorming sometimes the best
way to do it is to not do
it out loud, but to write.
Because as soon as you start
doing it out loud, the
conversation and the thoughts
go in that direction.
Whereas if you spend five
minutes and you just list out
the things that you want to
then bring up, or you have
people do this before the
meeting, but sometimes it's
easier to do it in a meeting.
If you have them all write it
out while silent and then put
it on the white board, or with
the sticky notes, or whatever,
you're going to find that you're
going to have a lot
more variety of ideas.
And that the people who tend
to be quieter, and I'm sure
there's people here in Google
that are very outspoken and
people that are quiet and
sometimes the most brilliant
folks, that will not
overshadow them.
So that's just one technique
for meetings.
I hope it helps.
But yeah, there's so many
different things that one can
do with meetings.
But stick to the agenda, respect
people's time, show up
on time, and just try to not
make it so the people that
overpower meetings overpower
meetings.
So thank you guys so much for
your time, I'll be sticking
around here.
And this is how to
get in touch.
I appreciate it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]